what do these two movies have in common
more than you might think
production-wise at least the scene where
the creature swims below the
unsuspecting K is not only beautiful and
iconic it helped craft another famous
water-based horror scene Steven
Spielberg borrowed elements from the
scene for Jaws opening moments some
scenes are even shot for shot each woman
dives into the water and there's a long
shot of them swimming happily until the
perspective shifts to focus on the
female swimmer from the monster point of
view sure we get to see Gilman and the
Creature from the Black Lagoon and not
Spielberg shark but both films have a
similar mashup of Haunting Beauty and
abject
Terror all the better to emphasize the
fear of what lurks below the water oh
and another fun fact the cry the shark
lets out at the end after it's blown up
yeah that's a modified version of
Gilman's Roar you son of
a